you Henderson Police swearing in their
new Chief today Holly Chadwick 8 news
now reporter Victoria Saha in Henderson
tonight with what members of the
department are saying about their new
boss
[Music]
Chief Holly Chadwick being sworn in
surrounded by members of the Henderson
Police Department many have been working
alongside her for 21 years some of you
are with me at the Academy graduation
and now you're here with me today Chief
Chadwick no stranger to the turbulence
the department has faced in recent years
not one but two police Chiefs leaving
abruptly Chief Chadwick not going into
much detail about what led her to take
the new role but she made sure to thank
her supporters you know I will get this
done the right way we are so grateful
for our community every day when we come
to work that is our sole focus is to
protect and serve this community back in
November two police unions voted no
confidence in previous Chief Frederick
Andres he retired in February Lieutenant
Chris agar president of Henderson Police
supervisors Association is looking
forward to seeing the new Chief in
action she's a big proponent of
communication between everyone so
everybody knows where they're all at
lieutenant agar tells me when he was a
sergeant Chief Chadwick was his captain
so he knows what kind of a leader she is
we had an officer injured or in the
middle of the night 2 am she wants the
phone call she wants to know what's
going on she wants to know that we're
taking care of the officer and you're
very confident that those qualities will
follow her to the chief's chair
absolutely and I know I think the good
thing about that is that she will lay
out those expectations for the people
that work below her as Deputy Chiefs and
captains that she would expect the same
thing from them
as you heard in that story there this is
the third chief for the Henderson Police
Department since 2017. now before Cedric
Andres Leticia Watson was in charge but
she was let go in 2019 and there are
still legal proceedings between the city
and Watson